today is the last day to participate in
this year's great eight or the great toy
drive you can help by dropping off a new
unwrapped toy at any tobin dealership in
town telus international is
co-sponsoring with tobin and noreen
sindelbach from telus international
joins us to talk more about the campaign
that's going to make christmas brighter
for a lot of kids and already it's been
going very well it has been going
fantastically we've collected uh
probably over 350 pieces of toys
anywhere from ages 1 to 17.
our team members ti family telus
international family has been great with
giving to this event it's something
that's near and dear to our hearts
giving back to our community is
something that we've done since we
started in 2008 in vegas and we continue
to do that on a yearly basis and you do
it not only here in las vegas but all
over the place you're from atlanta i am
from atlanta um i live in atlanta i
support the us and canada and we
actually just opened a new site in north
charleston and we're doing it there as
well
um just to get them going and it's it's
really in our dna to give back to our
community uh we understand the
importance of making sure that we
strengthen the community that we work in
that our team members live in uh to
ensure that you know that community is
healthy to help support us and support
the people that work with us it's
certainly very much appreciated tell us
about telus international for those
aren't who are familiar um so tell us
international uh we're like i said we
started in las vegas in 2008 but we are
over 56 000 team members worldwide
um in over 25 countries um and in vegas
we started with only a few hundred team
members in 2008 and now
we are almost at 2 000 team members we
provide next generation digital
solutions for our clients
to help drive their business and really
what that means is we help our clients
use technology to help drive their
business results
and it has to be gratifying to be with a
business that is giving back to
communities as you are with a great toy
drive absolutely what are some of the
results you've seen and your four years
will tell you in the time i've been here
it's it's it's fantastic when i just
started one of the first things that i
did i got a video of
one of our tea dog events which is our
telus days of giving events and that's
where we give back to our community on a
large scale and i remember showing the
video to my child and she goes mommy you
work for the best company in the world
they must be the most kindest company
and that made me feel proud that i'm
going to work for a company that i you
know i can tell people about that gives
back to the community because that's
important to me too
and we do look for you know team members
who are going to join us who
understand and values what we value and
want to give back to their community as
well well and we especially appreciate
you because i learned before this
interview started you're from atlanta
you just happened to be here in las
vegas and they said by the way why did
you just go on television and do this
yes but we so appreciate uh the
involvement of telus international and
this great toy drive i love that we're
able to do this and we'll continue to do
it and you know if you're out there
watching and you want to participate
it's the last day but we still have time
we'll take some more toys i mean if you
want to join a company that really loves
its community and want to give back to
the community this is a great place to
do it we're a wonderful organization to
work for two good pitches right there
noreen thanks so much today is the last
day to take part in the great toy drive
we've teamed up with tobin auto group
and telus international you can drop off
a new unwrapped toy or even a gift card
at any of the dealerships that you see
on your screen the donations will
benefit the shade tree organization